I'm giving this talk on behalf of Jacob
Schreiber Jacob is a PhD student at the
University of Washington in computer
science Jacob unfortunately he just
started a internship at Tesla that's not
the unfortunate part the unfortunate
part is that he couldn't get off to give
this talk so I'm giving it on his behalf
he is the primary author of the tool I'm
going to be telling you about so I'll do
my best to answer your questions but if
you have any other questions his contact
information is on this slide he says
please feel free to contact him using
any of these methods of social media in
particular if you have questions that I
can't answer I'll encourage you to tweet
them at him and I believe he is online
during this talk so hopefully he'll
tweet back right away and then I you
once you get the answer raise your hand
and then tell her and what the answer
was so we can do kind of a remote a
question and answer my name is Max
Labrecque I am currently a postdoc in at
the University of Washington I'm
affiliated with both the genome Sciences
in the computer science department I'm
in the same research group as Jacob we
both work on computational biology I'll
be starting as an assistant professor at
Simon Fraser University in Vancouver BC
at the end of the month if you're
interested in there's no puking about
pomegranate website but I have my
website there if you're interested in
reading about my research so please in
this talk feel free to ask me questions
any time and like I said if there are
questions that I can't answer feel free
to email or tweet at Jacob this talk is
about pomegranate which is a Python
toolkit for fast and flexible
probabilistic modeling and Python so
this talk is accompanied by a jupiter
notebook tutorial so the link here will
take you to a Jupiter and oppa that you
can download if you I you know if you're
here and you're remotely interested in
this I think actually the notebook is
probably even better way to understand
this than me talking at you so I
encourage you very strongly to
this link and download the notebook and
just open it on your computer and start
playing with the tools because that's a
really nice way to just get a sandbox
you can sort of plug in arguments to the
various functions I'll be telling you
about and see what happens so that link
is there for anyone who hasn't gotten a
chance to see it yet
also the link is going to be on the next
couple of slides just so that people
have time to to type it in okay
pomegranate is a tool for probabilistic
modeling so what do I mean by that
just very generally probabilistic
modeling is any case where you have some
data that's generated from some
uncertain process so those data values
they could be continuous real numbers
they could be discrete a binary yes/no
discrete categorical variables but in
general anytime you have information
that's generated in on certain way it's
usually a very effective it's very
effective to apply probabilistic
modeling to that data probabilistic
model lenses public modeling lends
itself well to a package because there
are sort of a core set of tasks that you
want to perform really as a
probabilistic modeling so very generally
if you have some probability
distribution you might want to sample
data from that distribution if you have
some data and you want to learn what
distribution generated that data you can
do that in a probabilistic framework or
in from kind of a prediction or machine
learning perspective you might want to
predict which of a number of
distributions generate a particular data
example and then be going a lot more
detail on this student so this is the
motivation for why pomegranate exist as
a toolkit to solve on sort of this this
category of tasks so supposing that
you're interested in public modeling
probabilistic modeling is a very large
field there are many problems associated
with it
and there are lots of tools that solve
probabilistic modeling related tasks so
what cases should you use pomegranate
for your problem so first thing I think
you can sort of divide your your tasks
into a continuum from very simple to
very complex so on the very simple side
you might have just a very simple
prediction task like logistic regression
you could just want to sample from a
Gaussian distribution and maybe you
don't care about speed because you just
this is just what you have to do at once
no big deal for those types of things
the very simple problems are available
in toolkit so you're probably already
using like SCI PI or scikit-learn so if
that's all you're trying to do you don't
need pomegranate pomegranate can
certainly solve these problems and
probably a little bit faster than these
tools but again if speed is an important
go father of pomegranate just just use
tools you're already using on the other
side odd the most cutting edge of
statistics research usually will be
implemented in custom packages that you
can usually access using our or in some
stands a lot
stand alone a command-line tool
unfortunately these days most statistics
research the first place it gets
implemented is still in our that's too
bad for us to like to use Python so you
know if you're trying to use that sort
of cutting edge you'll have to go to
these special tools so again that may be
cases where you have a distributions
that aren't available in pomegranate or
some very specific inference problem
that's related to your specific
application that needs to be really
really fast ok but for any anywhere in
between
I argue that pomegranate is a pretty
good solution so an advantage of
pomegranate it supports a lot of
different distributions I'll be telling
you about all the distributions
those are probability distributions all
the different distributions that it
supports today I'll argue and I hope the
taça Quincy that's pretty intuitive to
use and it's very flexible it's very
easy to a mix and match distributions to
your purposes and I'll be showing you
some cases about
how it's very fast okay so pomegranate
is great for these cases where you like
to use Python you have a problem that's
sophisticated enough that you can't use
these very widely used tools but you
know you don't need this this stuff that
you have to leave are for I'll leave
Python for I'm sorry okay so in some
other tasks it helpful to know I think
if you're interested in knowing when to
use a particular tool when you shouldn't
use that tool so I'm going to show you a
couple tools that are just a couple of
cases where pomegranate is not apply and
these are also a Python packages that
you may or may not be familiar with that
are probably useful in conjunction the
pomegranate okay so the first one is
scientific computing a pomegranate you
utilizes numpy inside pi a lot and
certainly if you're involved if you're
doing anything with data you probably
need to use uh numpy and sci-fi um if
you're doing supervised learning that
that can't be considered in a
probabilistic sense I'm not going to
really talk about what that means but
but forgetting simple support vector
machines and neural networks don't
really fit into this probabilistic
framework so well I'm going to show you
a couple faces of supervised learning
that do fit into the probabilistic
framework but for these examples you
probably have to use a different tool
kit for example scikit-learn it's really
lots about machine learning and
particularly in particular supervised
learning if you want to visualize any of
these models pomegranate doesn't do any
visualization itself I often use
something like that pot lid and then
maybe one of the toolkits that also that
in Python is most powerful for
probabilistic model modeling is this
toolkit called PI mz3 I don't know a lot
about Pi mg3 Jacob could tell you more
about the differences but if you're
interested in probabilistic modeling I
think you want to check out both
pomegranate and Pi mc3
hi I'm c3 I think is much more from the
bayesian philosophy of probabilistic
modeling
okay so that the structure of the talk
is I'm just going to give you a pretty
quick overview sort of the philosophy
behind pomegranate and what is very
features are and I'm going to go into
depth on some of its more more complex
and more powerful features in this
section here and then at the end I want
to show you how we can sort of leverage
all of the power of pomegranate to do
something you probably would have a
really hard time doing with most other
toolkits again if there any questions
please stop me these slides are not
online there are similar slides the
questions are the size of mine there
decides that these were based off of are
also on that github repository that you
can find from this link here sorry I
should have put the slides online before
this talk there they're almost the same
slides though this is just a couple of
changes any more questions
okay so like I said the beginning there
are common set of tasks you might want
to perform no matter what probability
distribution you're interested in so so
I said before you might want to sample
you might want to predict here is a
common API that pomegranite implements
for all of its models okay first thing
is you have a problem distribution you
can predict the probability of a
particular data example and you can
that's what the either the model dot
probability I'm getting some feedback
let me try to fix this okay you can pick
the probability or you can calculate the
probability of a given data example you
can sample values from a model so this
will you take the model you run sample
on it'll produce an X that's the same X
that you put in here you can take a
model with unknown parameters and use a
bunch of data that's this X to fit its
parameters and there some common primers
you can take with fitting for example
you can put a weight on each excuse me
you can put a weight on each data
example I'll tell you a little bit soon
about these idea of summaries and the
idea of a summary statistic and then you
can also for a subset of methods you can
if it's a mixture distribution or a
classifier model I'll tell you more
about those the second you can predict
which distribution a particular value
came from you can predict the
probability this has the same framework
if you're familiar with scikit-learn
so I could learn will you predict the
class or predict the probability of
different classes pomegranate will do
the same thing this is the same thing
with log and then I'll tell you well so
a pomegranate also has this idea of the
difference between fit and from samples
so these two methods are similar in the
sense that they they both take some a
collection of data and produce as output
a model with with fit parameters the
differencing the two is that fit is
designed for models where you have a
pretty specific idea of what you're
looking for for example on in a mixture
of Gaussian distributions you might
already know how many Gaussian
components you want to fit then you do
fit with the from samples it's intended
to be much you're imposing much less
Sharan the problem for example in a
gaussian case I believe it you don't
have to tell it how many components you
want you'll have to look at the
documentation for more for each for each
model exactly what the differencing fit
and and from samples is Appa that's just
the general philosophy difference
between the two okay so there are six
general categories of models that
pomegranate supports and we going
through all of these the first is just
basic probability distributions things
like a Gaussian distribution uniform
distribution the second is general
mixture models so pomegranate lets you
take any distributions you want and
produce a mixture of those together I'll
be telling you again about each of these
together Markov chain which is a way of
modeling sequences with probability
distributions hidden Markov models are
the same thing
Bayes classifiers which is a way of
performing supervised learning using a
in a probabilistic framework and then
Bayesian networks they're also a two
helper models in pomegranate these
probably are only useful you know as
because they support these other models
but they that they are a belated answer
that k-means plus plus k-means is a
clustering algorithm k-means barbar
that's scalable k-means is a sort of a
variant of that it's good for I believe
parallel architectures and then factor
graphs are used in Bayes networks okay
so like I said I'm going to just touch
on each of these categories of models in
turn okay so here is a list of I think
most of the base distributions the
pomegranate supports and I've colored in
red the ones that are commonly used
so for example a uniform distribution
that's just a distribution that's flat
so no difference between the different
values they could take a normal
distribution also called a Gaussian
distribution exponential distribution
these are probably you know
distributions that you would have heard
of in your you know basic probability
course
so what pomegranite it can you can
create one of these distributions you
can sample from it using that API that I
told you about just model dot sample you
can you can take a distribution and you
can create it from known values so in
this case we have we'd like to make a
normal distribution so a normal
distribution that's just a bell-shaped
Gaussian distribution it has two
parameters mu and Sigma the mean and the
standard deviation so you take this
normal distribution function defined in
pomegranate you pass in the MU and Sigma
and you get a which is a a pomegranate
model and then you can run any of those
any of those functions that I told you
about earlier you can do sample on it
you can do predict on it for example I'm
sorry here I'm just showing a couple
just very simple examples here's a case
where we made a couple of different
Gaussian distributions using pomegranate
okay and then you can also learn the the
parameters of a probability distribution
using pomegranate so in this case we use
numpy to make a bunch of random
variables you could also do this in
pomegranate of course so that how the
function work is it's you pass in the
mean and the variance so it's values of
mean 0 standard deviation 1 and we want
100 of these that's this data here at
the bottom so each dot is one of our
data
points and the horizontal axis is the
value of that data point and that's X is
just that big list of 100 values then we
can use pomegranate we take the normal
distribution class and we call from
samples 4 on it and we give it our data
X and what pomegranate will learn is
this normal distribution here and you
can see that it has approximately a mean
of 0 which is how we generate the day on
the first place so it looks like it's
doing ok one of the I think is the most
powerful features of pomegranate is that
it can handle this idea of model
stacking so that's where you take a one
type of model and use it as a sub model
in some wrapper model okay so what is
what does that mean so that it's more
simple in the case of a mixture model so
what I'm showing you here in this figure
is on the horizontal axis I have R both
axes I have the different different
classes of models in pomegranate so
again distributions based classifiers
classifiers Markov chains and so on and
then here it's just the acronym for the
same thing so it makes your distribution
is is just a distribution where you
imagine that you have some probability
of pulling from one distribution some
probability of pulling for different
distribution so each time you want to
generate a data example first you flip a
coin to decide which distribution you're
going to sample from and then you sample
from that distribution as you would
normally and then you output that value
so mixture distributions come up in all
sorts of cases I'm going to show you a
bunch of examples later but the
interesting thing about pomegranate is
you can take any distribution that
pomegranate implements and you can use
that as one of the components of a
mixture distribution so I'm showing you
here is there's a blue square anytime
that kind of input of one model into
another model is implemented so in this
case you can see that it's implemented
that distributions can be used as input
to GMs
meaning general mixture models
you can see a bunch of other cases too
so mixture models can be kind of
recursively input into each other and
then hidden Markov models can be input
as a component of mixture models as well
these light blue squares are features
that are in development so I think these
will be ready pretty soon so just if
this is something interesting get
checkout a you know watch for watch for
coming patches to pomegranate so we can
fill them this this table and look for
all different places where these things
are implemented to a hidden Markov model
what it means for a hidden Markov model
to have a sub model is that that sub
model is the emission distribution of
the hidden Markov model so like I said a
hidden Markov model is a probability
distribution over sequences so what
hidden Markov model implements is that
at every position you have some
distribution over what value could be
output at that sequence and you can see
a hidden Markov models you can put it as
input any distribution as the emission
distribution and even any mixture model
as the emission distribution and again
Bayes Nets you can implement you can use
as a mission distribution suit so here's
that full table so you can see that all
models can have a district just the base
distributions as their sub model Bayes
classifiers are sort of a different type
from everything else here because the
Bayes classifier isn't a probability
distribution itself it's a it's kind of
a supervised learning test so it doesn't
even make sense for for Bayes
classifiers we put his input into
something else so that's why this row is
empty I mean just go through so uhm
Bayes classifiers can have anything as
input and then I told you about these
two columns as well and you can see that
soon is coming that Markov chains can
have a Markov changes input as well okay
and this is like I said this is one of
the most exciting features of
pomegranate specifically because
this feature of model stacking as far as
we can tell isn't really available
anywhere else so what I'm showing here
is cases where so this is the squares in
this plot are just a subset of the
squares in the previous plot and these
are places where as far as we know no
other widely used package implements
that particular type of model stacking
so the red is places or have a yes or
the dark right is places that
pomegranate implements that as far as we
can tell no one else does the the orange
is places where there are some other
implementations but they're far less
fully featured than exists in
pomegranate so I think this is one of
the the biggest cases for using
pomegranate is the fact that whatever
type of distribution you might be
interested you can kind of mix and match
you can plug one distribution or another
and it means that almost any problem
that you might be interested in it
probably solved by some stacking of one
model into another I'll show you a
couple of examples of how we can use
that soon okay another great thing about
pomegranate is it's very fast so here
I'm just showing you a really simple
example where we are
computing the mean and standard
deviation of a bunch of data so here we
create some data using numpy and then we
we compute the mean and standard
deviation using numpy using this
time--it function and we do the same
thing using pomegranate excuse me i'm
she to output is down here you see numpy
took about a 45 microseconds per loop
pomegranate took about 20 microseconds
the reason for this is just that numpy
is trying to be very general it doesn't
there's no way to tell it that when
you're going through a bunch of data you
want to be computing both the mean and
receiver standard deviation at the same
time so basically it's traveling through
the data twice and that's why it's about
twice twice the running time where
pomegranate I'll tell you
I it it can do it with just one data
pass coming up it's based on this idea
of summary statistics okay so that was a
very simple example that just took a
couple microseconds let's do a slightly
more intense example so here again we
have a bunch of data we want to compute
oh and this is a this is 10 data from a
10 dimensional multivariate Gaussian now
and we want to compute both the mean and
the covariance matrix and looks like
again pomegranate is a bit faster I'm
okay so why why is it that pomegranate
is faster so the reason pomegranate is
so fast is it uses this this library
called Blas I don't actually know a
blast stands for but it's a it's a
linear algebra a toolkit it's written I
believe originally Fortran and it's sort
of hyper optimized so a pomegranate uses
blast but numpy also uses blast so
that's not where the running time is
coming from the reason pomegranate gets
to be faster is it's a more specific
tool kit then numpy so what happens in
numpy is it ends up numpy ends up going
back and forth between Python and and
Fortran but really it's machine code all
the time which just slows things down
where's pomegranate doesn't have to do
that because it can use these top level
calls to blast so just one one call into
blast and not these these repeated calls
in and out um okay another thing if
you're interested in running times that
pomegranate does is it nearly supports a
GPU you can you can use a GPU to run
pomegranate a GPU the everything
pomegranate will run without it but if
you have one available pomegranate will
use it and it's through this package
called cu py
and then you can see the running time of
some different to different tasks using
the GPU versus not so you can see this
this this bar is the node GPU bar and
the right is the GPU bar and you can see
of course GPUs offer a lot of power
especially for tasks that are paralyzed
able and this turns out the attachment
is paralyzed well and the GPU is a lot
faster and of course this is a case with
lots of examples if you have a small
amount of data it's not going to matter
whether I use a GP or no data or a GPU
or no GPU okay so I was telling you
about how pomegranate lets you compute
these statistics like they mean and the
variance which is one pass of the data
so how does it do this and uses this
idea of sufficient statistics so a
sufficient statistic is a statistics a
concept from the field of statistics
which says if you have a bunch of data
you can in many cases compute a small
number of sufficient statistics that's
the name of these numbers numbers called
sufficient statistics that will tell you
all you need to know about that about
that data as a pertaining to a
particular probability distribution so
let's use as our example the uh normal
distribution it turns out if you have a
ton of data and it actually doesn't
matter how much data you can summarize
everything you need for normal
distribution using three numbers the
number of data points or if it's
weighted just the sum of the weights
so again if all the way through one then
this would just be the number of data
points the sum of all the values in your
data sets and you can weight or not
weight and the sum of the squares and I
and I'm showing you on the right how you
compute the mean and the variance using
just these three quantities so you can
see in the case the mean you take this
number that's number number two
or I should say submission statistics
number two you divide statistic number 2
divided by statistic number 1 to compute
the variance you take a sufficient
statistic number 3 divided by number 1 -
number 2 squared divided by number 1
squared so it turns out that that these
equations compute successfully the mean
and variance and again you only need
these numbers so that's how pomegranate
got that speed up is that in its first
pass through the data
it was just computing these three
sufficient statistics and then ever
after it never had to look at the data
again it can just reference these
statistics now a really valuable thing
about suspicion statistics is that I
they help you support parallelization so
it turns out that those three statistics
in the case of a mobile distribution are
additive meaning you can take you can
compute the sufficient statistics on one
set of data you can compute it on
another set of data and then if you want
to know what the statistics are for the
full set of data you just add each pair
of specific statistics so I here's an
example of us doing that so we are
trying to fit our model for a bunch of
data maybe this is like a ton of data in
this case I think it's 5,000 data points
you could just fit it on the whole data
set above that you could only do on one
core and so that one core would have to
go through all of the data at once but
equivalently you can use this function
that propagate the influence called
summarize so what summarize does is it
goes through the data set and computes
that the sufficient statistics on the
data you give it so in this case we
could take five threads running on five
different cores compute the sufficient
statistics on each on a 1/5 of the data
in
case and then run this function from
summaries on all those statistics
question I believe this isn't real code
I believe this is this is just some
chimp code that we threw up so so I
think what this does is outputs the
statistics and then you you produce and
then you give it the statistics here I
in it should be that in the in the
jupiter notebook there should be a case
where you actually go through the whole
thing and compare the running time so if
you want to know how to do this for real
I think it was just too much code to put
on a slide so you wonder how to do it
this real I'll check out the notebook to
enter your question questions yeah
you're worried about it so the question
is if you have a really large mean and a
really small variance how accurate is
the computation so your question is
about numerical precision I'm guessing I
don't know the answer that um
right that I can see how that be a
problem to two solutions out one is just
to change your your floating-point
precision of course and two of course
for me to change how you're doing
computation so if your internet a tweet
Jacob I'm guessing he's done that
experiment at some point and can
probably point you to the results but I
don't know they answered that more
questions
yeah okay I'm going to go a couple
slides okay here's the URL it's down in
the bottom here let's actually let's go
over here yeah this one here's here's a
notebook like I said all of the results
I'm showing you are computed on this
notebook so you can just download the
notebook and then any result I'm showing
you can just find the part of the
notebook that implements that result you
just play with it you can try again
changing the mean to be really big in
the variants we really small and seeing
what happens you can just anything you
want to play with this here I think that
like I said this is one of the best ways
to sort of get to know a toolkit the
whole repository
oh yeah that's another thing you can do
is here's the here's Jacob's github
which has pomegranate you can also just
clone the whole thing any more questions
and keep this up so people can see the
URL okay yes I'll do my best to do that
yeah
I don't know anything about the notebook
the question was what it is a Python 2
notebook the answer is yes it is Python
2 the only I think Python 3
compatibility issue it sounds like is
that there's needs to have parentheses
around the print statements so you just
put in those parentheses it'll work
questions around the map put lifts
around the map function yeah I believe
so the question is what happens if your
distribution does not have sufficient
statistics I I'm not I believe all of
powertrains distributions do have
sufficient statistics another thing you
can do is you can just store the whole
data set as sort of a if you need to
implement some distribution that doesn't
support them of course that has a big
memory implication and of course we're
running kind of implication because
every time you have to go through all
the data but it doesn't it's not
strictly excluded from this kind of
framework aerial questions okay here's
here's sort of a picture for another
thing is to do parallelization you take
your whole dataset you can split it into
chunks ah use one core each to compute
the summaries on those chunks and then
add the opinion sufficient statistics
together and then compute your parameter
on those statistics okay
another feature part yes another
question
the question is is pomegranate doing
threading on its own I don't know the
answer that question okay another
feature of pomegranate is
semi-supervised learning so so what
incent me to provides learning you're
trying to perform a supervised learning
task meaning I distinguish some class of
examples for some from some other class
so for example this could be spam emails
you're trying to figure out what emails
are spam and what emails are not spam
based on the context of email in a semi
supervised problem you have both labeled
data that's these colored points and
unlike a strict supervised problem you
also have a bunch of unlabeled data on
that that's those gray points here so in
a semi supervised case so intently
supervised learning what we do is we fit
a probability distribution over each
class so a probability distribution over
red and purple then we assign all the
unlabeled data to one of those two
classes based on whether or not it based
on those distributions then we use that
data as labeled data and fit new
distributions and then go back and forth
sitting on the unlabeled data and
updating our distributions and actually
there are teal points here I don't think
this is showing up in projector but
there's a bunch of teal teal points down
here of course you can't see them so um
so why why you sent me to provide
learning so in the left case I'm showing
you what happens when we perform a
supervised learning and you can see and
what I'm showing you here is these black
lines are the decision boundaries where
the classifier draws lines between
different classes so in this case the
any point that's in this little sliver
here it will assign as red
every point in this like sort of be
shaped thing here it's going to assign
as purple and everything down here is
going to sign SQ this is not super
satisfying because these decision
boundaries look kind of unrealistic like
it's I mean it's course it's going to be
very problem dependent you know how you
interpret these but it's weird for a
class to have this like sort of sliver
shape so in a semi-supervised case you
can think of it kind of as
regularization using the unlabeled data
so I what this procedure requires is
that all the data that those students
out Rees should respect the shape of the
underlying data pretty well so what the
in the Sun to provide the summer
supervised method is seeing is that
there's this chunk of data and we don't
have very many labeled examples in it
but it's a pretty good guess that all of
these come from the same class and they
seem to be they seem to have this shape
of probabilities probability
distribution so the semi-supervised
learner is assigning excuse me this
decision boundary this sort of respects
the density of the data so you see lots
of cases very often in for example an
image and text analysis where
semi-supervised analysis performs much
better than supervised because it really
leverages sort of the distribution of
the underlying data
semi-supervised analysis makes a lot of
sense in this probabilistic framework so
that's right why it's really well-suited
to something like pomegranate okay a
couple more analyses of running time so
i here what we're doing is we're
calculating the running time of fitting
multivariate Gaussian distributions so
so here we're generating some data
so here's here to regenerate the data we
have to two ways of of computing the
probability of this data either using
five pi which which can prove compute
the probability distribution according
to a multivariate Gaussian and using
pomegranate and you can see a
pomegranate is doing about half the
running time you can see a pomegranate
takes 800 milliseconds side pipe takes
double that 1.6 milliseconds and then we
can even do a little bit better with
pomegranate by pre creating this model
object so instead of initializing a
distribution in each case and then
computing the probability on it we first
initialize the distribution and then
just continually and we're not counting
the time for for initializing the
distribution in this in the store
anytime in case that's way faster this
is about a quarter of the running time
of even the normal upon grant time and
it ate the running time of sci-fi okay
so why is this so much faster
pomegranate uses caching really
aggressively in all its computations so
what I'm showing you here is these are
on the top two equations are the
equations for computing the density
according to our normal distribution and
the key thing to note here is it
involves this X function so X is the
exponent function meaning e
to the value in here and it's a pretty
expensive function to compute same thing
happens if you if you're computing the
log probability the X goes away here but
the log comes in here the same problem
with log it's pretty expensive to
compute now the trick is is that if
you've already computed on this number
log of root 2 pi times Sigma if you were
to computed that then you can compute
the log probability with no logs
or no logs or XP's so what's happening
in that previous example is that oh and
I hear say that this is so an the key
thing to note is that this is constant
for a fixed distribution so if you have
already computed this for a given
distribution you only have to compete at
once so what's happening in that
previous example is that pomegranate pre
computed this and then each time it's
trying to do some probability
calculation it doesn't have to recompute
it and I think what's going on with side
PI is it hasn't done that caching and so
it's recomputing it's computing a log at
each loop so it's quite a bit slower any
questions about this okay so next I'm
going to show you an example this is I
think you know really important example
shows how real-world applicable
pomegranate is so here's here's the
field of research okay I'm just kidding
this is this is kind of a fluffy example
listen about the show Gossip Girl this
give me example of kind of how you can
apply this in practice I'm going to say
that there we're gonna take a break
after this do you have a chance to have
a snack stretch your legs if you are no
fun you don't wanna hear about Gossip
Girl this would be a good thing to miss
okay so there's a show Gossip Girl it's
I think it's about ten years ago oh
another thing is there's many spoilers
for Gossip Girl so you're already
spoiled don't don't listen
okay so Gossip Girl is kind of your your
typical TV drama there are a bunch of
teenagers in Manhattan they take turns
hooking up with each other and basically
disappointing their parents
so so what happened is that Jacob and
his girlfriend like to watch this show
and of course Jacob you know was working
on pomegranate at the time and so we had
to apply probabilistic modeling to try
to figure out what's going to happen in
the show okay so in in gossip girl
there's this enigmatic character named
gossip girl who will send out these text
messages to all the characters in the
show called blast just to like stir up
trouble so here's an example of one of
these blasts spotted lonely boy can't
believe the level of his life has
returned if only she knew who he was but
everyone knows Serena and everyone is
talking wonder what Blair Waldorf thinks
sure they're BFFs but we always thought
that Blair's boyfriend Nate had a thing
for Serena okay you can see just like
lots of drama going on in this text
message so I so Jacobs idea was it we
want to try to figure out who Gossip
Girl is because in the show we don't
know who Gossip Girl is and there's this
assumption it's got a little probably
one of the main characters so so Jacobs
idea was that you can probably figure
out who Gossip Girl might be because
Gossip Girl is going to be trying to
advance their agenda you know probably
saying bad things about other characters
and good things about themselves so
here's an example of a one of these
blasts better lock it down Nate B
clock's ticking so you can see the very
lockdown with Nate the B is one of the
characters I guess probably Bridgette
right or Blair sorry so so this text a
sort of in Nate's favor right because
it's trying to convince Blair to you
know what date him or whatever and then
and then it's not in Blair's interest
because you know she's being she doesn't
want to date him apparently okay so we
can do lots of examples I here's another
one s and B two characters are stealing
from a store and it's reporting you know
Gossip Girl is reporting this so this
one is just bad for everyone it's saying
bad things about both these characters
okay so you know these are lots to do
throughout the show and you know we're
going to try to use some probabilistic
modeling to to solve this but what if
let's try
not doing any probabilistic modeling
people you solve it before so here's
what we did if we just take all those
pluses and minuses from their home
character integers add them up and what
you can see here they're free characters
on the top and the show and it looks
like this character has lots of bad
things being said about her so we could
figure out that she is probably not
Gossip Girl but we haven't figured out
yet because these three characters all
have the same sum so we don't know which
one Gossip Girl is okay but we can do we
can do better with probabilistic
modeling okay so the probabilistic
modeling we're going to do is using the
beta distribution this is really
important stuff you guys don't fall
asleep okay so the beta distribution is
a way of modeling uncertainty in a in a
public process so what a beta
distribution imagines is that you have
some coin and you don't know what the
probability of the coin coming up heads
or tails is but you've observed some
number of coin flips so what this is
showing is that the horizontal axis is
the different possible values for the
probability of coin coming up heads and
then the vertical axis is the
probability that we think that that's
the real weight of the coin and you can
see here's what the probability is for
different numbers of observed coin
tosses so if we haven't observed any
well with just a uniform distribution
over the different values if we've
observed a bunch of heads and tails and
it's an equal number we can be pretty
sure that the coin is roughly a fair
coin if we've observed one heads and two
tails well we don't really know if it's
fair or not there's a pretty good chance
of it's fair but certainly from our best
guess would be that it's unfair and
weighted towards tails okay so we're
going to do the same thing for the show
so we're imagining a gossip girl is
flipping coins and gossip girl is
deciding who or who to slander or
promote you know based on what they get
from the coin and have a coin for each
character and of course gossip girl's
coin is going to be you know more
weighted they're saying
good things towards themselves okay
so here's what we get from this analysis
after season 1 of the show Jacob went
through this is a you know important
life-changing thing research had to go
and hold for this he went in categories
all the blasts according to who the text
slandered and then and then made a beta
distribution for each character so you
can see that ok so Jenny is probably oh
sorry
I think we want we uh so being on the
right means that you have good things
said about you be on the left means you
have bad things said about you so here
is Jenny Jenny is having lots of bad
things said about her and Dan is having
lots of good things said about her him
but but these distributions all overlap
so we can't really tell who's who's who
or you know
it could be that the red is actually
higher than the green we just don't know
yet and of course the person who is
Gossip Girl should be the distribution
that's farthest on the right here okay
here's what you get after you go through
the different seasons so they're
probably the four seasons total of
Gossip Girl and here's how these beta
distributions evolved as you get more
data so this is this is a beta
distribution after you include all the
data from season one and season two then
here is season 1 season 2 and season 3
and then all of a seasons together now
unfortunately we don't really get a
clear answer Jacobs theory is it is not
the best analysis bad it's just that the
creators of the show didn't decide who
Gossip Girl and just pick one randomly
at the end maybe that's maybe that's
true maybe that's hot maybe they had a
plan but so what our analysis did show
you can see just by a bit Dan looks like
he came out the best in here spoiler Dan
is Gossip Girl so I that's that's the
answer the show and and we kind of use
probabilistic modeling to get it and you
can do this with pomegranate
all right take a five-minute break maybe
like eight brilliant break we're going
to come back at to take a minute to
stretch your legs have a drink of water
I'll be back at 2:00 2:00 p.m. all right
so continuing on with to talk about
pomegranate so what I gave you before
was the overview of sort of the larger
features of pomegranate now I'm going to
go into detail about some of the more
complicated and the more powerful
features of pomegranate and the first
one is general mixture models okay so in
many cases in real data we have the case
where it looks like our data is
generated not from a single base
distribution but maybe a mixture of
those based distributions so in this
case what it really looks like this data
is generated by two gaussians one
Gaussian distribution here and one
Gaussian distribution here so we can
model this really easily using a
pomegranate by saying we are going to
learn a general mixture model that's a
pomegranate class from samples and we
are saying that we're going to use two
normal distributions and this is the
data we're giving it and this red line
is the distribution that we get so it
looks pretty good
it's modeling one hump here when I'm
here matches the data pretty well and
I'm not showing this here but it's based
on one Gaussian distribution here and
one here and you can see we're using the
from samples call
so what from samples is going to do it
turns out in this case is it first runs
k-means k-means plus plus I believe
quickly on the data to generate initial
initial and the initialization and then
it runs the e/m algorithm to iteratively
update those Gaussian distributions and
does that for all mixture models so
that's just a quick way of initializing
it's not the optimal way but it
turns out that is intractable to find
what the best optimization or what the
best initialization is so that that's a
pretty good heuristic and it can either
use k-means plus plus or k-means barbar
that's the scalable k-means they're
somewhere that you can set that option
so when people think about when they see
the acronym GMM they think about a
Gaussian mixture model but actually
pomegranate supports general mixture
models mixtures of any types of
distributions so in this case you might
look at this data and it looks kind of
like an exponential distribution maybe
because you know it's high here and low
here that's what the shape of the
exponential distribution is here's what
happens when we try to model it with a
single exponential distribution again
exponential distribution that's one of
the base distributions in pomegranate
and you can see doesn't look so good
it's too low at the beginning and it
looks like it tails off too fast in the
tail so so this this is not so good
turns out that you can do a little
better by using a mixture of two
exponential distributions so what this
is doing is it's using one very steep
exponential distribution the to model
this part of the tail and then one
shallow exponential distribution or the
shallow exponential distribution models
the tail the first one models this first
part question the question is can you
combine different distributions that's
an excellent question so the answer is
yes you can so here's what you do you
can just take general mixture model and
you can put in a list of different
distributions that you'd like in this
case we're trying to model this using an
exponential distribution and a uniform
distribution that might be a good
mixture if you think your data has some
signal and then just a bunch of uniform
noise in this case it turns out doesn't
look so good but you can imagine a case
where or I mean you can this is just
supposed to be showing it you can do it
and you could certainly imagine a case
where do well question
yes so you have to decide in order to
make a mixture model what distribute ups
right question was do you have to decide
what what distributions you're using the
answer is yes you do you could imagine a
strategy where you try like all
different combinations of distributions
and pick the one that gives you the best
likelihood that's not it blended in
pomegranate but you can actually doing
it do I have intuition about how you
would come up with with this set of
distributions it's just your intuition
about the data and maybe from you know
looking at some some data you've held
out for exploratory analysis so for
example um in real data most real data
because of sort of the central limit
theorem most data ends up being Gaussian
so it's usually a pretty good bet to
model your data using some sort of
mixture of gaussians maybe you think
your data is generated from a Gaussian
but then it's exponentiated in that case
you might want to use a log normal
distribution that's the example or if
you think your bit is just noisy and
there's just some uniform noise maybe
you want to put in uniform but again
it's just your instigation you have to
understand what the process is that's
generating your particular dataset so I
notice you use the graph you have this
little kind of linked gallop
because you can eyeball that crap right
from your college so the question is I
could eyeball this and say it looks like
two distributions yeah it's hard I don't
have a good answer it's hard is the
answer I think if we knew if we could
figure this out
maybe machines would have already taken
over so good good that that pomegranate
can't do this okay any more questions do
I have examples of higher dimensional
data I think the best example I have for
you let's go back to which slide is this
one this is a multivariate Gaussian
distribution I don't know the full set
of where pomegranate supports
multi-variant and where it supports
univariate so the answer your question
okay um here is some running time so
this is fitting a multivariate Gaussian
to components that's uh that's a feature
that scikit-learn also has but it turns
out that pomegranate does a bit faster
it turns out that they're implementing
the same algorithm pomegranate is just
doing better caching sort of ends up
performing a little faster
so what I'm showing you here is on the
vertical axis is how many times faster
pomegranate is you can see that it's
never below excuse me it's ever below
one one is this line here so it's
pomegranate doing faster all the time
and the it looks like forfeiting that's
the preferred prediction is the purple
pomegranate faster and it's a bit faster
forfeiting so looks good questions about
general mixture models okay so moving on
to hidden Markov models so a hidden
Markov model is a way of defining a
probability distribution over a sequence
of examples so mixture models come up a
lot in my field of research
computational biology because or
specifically in genetics because you can
think of the genome sequence is a big
sequence of letters a C T and G for
letters and you can model that using
hidden Markov model hidden Markov models
also come up and then type of time
series data like like in finance also in
natural language sometimes because you
can think of words in the sentence as
following this the sequence structure so
what a hidden Markov model does is at
each position you you imagine that the
hidden Markov model is in some state and
it has certain mission probabilities of
what character it commits based on what
state it's in on in this case just a
very simple example let's imagine we're
looking for parts of the genome that's
part of this sequence of DNA letters
that has more season G's versus
tee's it turns out in the real human
genome that does occur often more
functional elements have more season
geez why that is it's complicated and
maybe we don't really know but but you
might want to look for it using
probabilistic modeling so we can do that
using a hidden Markov model and the way
we we show a hidden Markov model is
using this state notation where we can
go into - we go between two states
either we're in an island of CGS meaning
more CGS than we expect or we're in the
background and we imagine that if we're
in a CG Island at position I we have a
90 percent chance of staying in the
island and a 10% chance of switching and
in the background we have a 90 percent
chance of staying and 10% chance of
switching as well and then we imagine we
start in one of the two randomly with 50
percent probability
so here Markov models are really easy to
implement using pomegranate and it looks
like this so what we're going to do is
first we're going to define
distributions for the two states we
could be in so d1 is it can be for one
state d2 is going to the other I think
the one is for background so for a
background we have an equal probability
of all the four letters in d2 we have a
forty percent probability each an 80%
probability total for being in season
G's and twenty percent probability for
being a MT then we define States that's
a state for hmm state these are all
pomegranate classes we give it that
distribution it's a by the way to just
screech distribution that's one of the
base distributions the pomegranate
supports and we give it a name and this
gets background at CG island then we
define a hidden Markov model to have the
name that we call it CG detector we put
in these states and then we put in all
the transitions that we want so we're
going to put a put a tradition
transition from the start to state one
with 50% start state to 50% state one to
state one ninety percent to one to two
to ten percent and so on
and then the very last step to making a
hidden Markov model is to make this bake
to call this bake function that just
tells pomegranate it's time to do all
the caching it needs to do before you
actually apply it to something
another thing by the way is you can
there's a way to take into a matrix of
the input rather than doing a bunch of
individual function calls
that's just useful so here are the
features of pomegranate compared to
another package for hidden markov models
called hmm learn hmm learn is a Python
package that's pretty widely used for
hidden Markov models you can see there's
a check mark where pomegranate has a
feature and a check mark where hmm learn
has a feature this is something that was
a table that was developed by hmm learn
so we didn't we didn't make this and you
can see there's some cases where hm and
learn has some feature we don't have
pomegranate doesn't have priors yet for
example but there's a bunch of cases
where we have features that hmmm learn
doesn't have on the most useful ones are
probably these graphs structure or
modeling features so these are cases
where if you think your data for example
has silent states meaning a state that
doesn't produce any output you can model
that using pomegranate but not using hmm
learn and there's a bunch of examples of
that so of course if if you thought your
data was distributed that way you you
just be out of luck with hmm learn
question
I don't actually know what Pryor's is
corresponding to the question is is
isn't this a prior of these the start
transitions and I think they're using
priors to mean something else and I'm
not exactly sure so you'll have to look
at this table there's probably like some
a caption that says exactly what they
mean which one is sorry I don't know the
answer to that question
any more questions okay
now we can we can show an example of
this stacking by we're going to stack
three things on top of each other we're
going to make a hidden Markov model
where the emission distribution is a
mixture model and that mixture model is
of normal distributions okay so this is
really showing how that stacking
functionality is really useful so in
this case before we had that discrete
distribution as our emission
distribution here in this case we just
replaced that line with a general
mixture model and this is just some
mixture that we're defining the
parameters of so this so now this would
be a hidden Markov model over real
numbers so I don't why you definitely
you want to do this but you can
certainly imagine a case where you would
and the code here it's exactly the same
except for these two lines so just a
very simple switch and this is speed
comparison between pomegranate hmmm
learn again pomegranates quite a bit
faster so again the axis is the number
of times that pomegranates faster and
you can see one is like down here so
pomegranates always faster there's no
points below one well and so the most
important line is probably the training
time because that's usually the most
expensive part of a hidden Markov model
and you can see that pomegranates quite
a bit faster and it gets and the degree
to which is faster increases as the size
of the problem grows I believe the
horizontal axis is the number of
of that the hit a kid market model
questions about hidden Markov models
okay so we're going to go onto Bayes
Nets Bayesian networks so a Bayesian
network is just a way to define a
multivariate distribution meaning a
distribution over a bunch of different
variables now a Bayesian network has a
particular structure that it says that
some that an arrow in this graph
structure means that this variable is
conditionally dependent on this variable
so sprinkler is conditionally dependent
on rain just to make this concrete this
is a pretty simple probabilistic example
it can either be raining or could not be
raining there you could turn on the
sprinkler and whether you turn it on
depends on whether it's rain raining
because if there's dirty rain you're
probably not going to turn on the
sprinkler and then whether or not the
grass is wet depends on the grass is wet
if either the sprinkler turned on or the
rain rain happened okay so I so you can
see in this particular example that
sprinkler depends just on rain of course
whether or not you turn on the sprinkler
doesn't depend on grass of course
because that sprinklers defining whether
not grass is wet and then nothing is
determining whether or not rain falls
that's just random and then again grass
depends on both of these you know
whether or not both of these happens so
these edges indicate conditional
dependence and the really important
thing is that if there is no edge it
means there's conditional independence
so if you know whether or not rain
occurred you can figure out what the
full probability distribution is for
sprinkler and you don't need to know if
the grass is wet now it turns out that
this structure makes inference really
efficient in some cases
because the inference algorithms can
take advantage of this graph structure
you can sometimes compute probabilities
of over one part of the graph without
having to consider all of different
possibilities for another part of the
graph so I'm not going to talk in detail
about those inference algorithms but
they're implemented by pomegranate and
it means that for some structures of
models using those algorithms is much
much much faster than thinking about it
as just a general multivariate
distribution Bayes Nets are also really
valuable because they're very
interpretable you can you can look at
you know the structure of variables and
that usually makes sense intuitively and
you can also look at each conditional
dependence and you can see exactly how
one variable depends on all the others
so there are two tasks you might want to
perform in a Bayes net
the first is inference in that network
and the second is learning what the
dependency structure is so very quickly
I'm going to show you example of a
lonely just very quickly explain a rough
example of how Bayes net inference works
if you want to learn more about this you
can google the voice propagation
algorithm that's the algorithm that
pomegranite implements so what happens
is that basically I there's information
there's like a message passing algorithm
where there are different what are
called factors that that have
information about different sets of
variables and you pass information from
factors to marginal distributions over
each variable and basically by passing
messages you can compute things about
this network without having to eat
perform computations over the entire
network at once okay let's look at an
example for how this works so I'm
showing you here a toy medical
diagnostic network
so what I'm showing you here is on the
top our different genetic mutations you
could have so these are just names of
different genes in the middle our
different conditions you could have this
is ovarian cancer a lactose intolerance
and pregnancy and then at the bottom are
different symptoms you could have low
energy bloating loss of appetite
vomiting and abdominal cramps okay so so
a great way that you can use this
probabilistic model is maybe you have
observed some edit before I go into that
here's just the probabilities you get
without any information and you can see
it the probability of any of these
things happening is pretty low again
this is completely toy-like all these
numbers are made up but there may be at
a realistic who knows so here's what
happens if you observe some of these
values so in this case we we find a
person who has low energy have bloating
and they have vomiting and then we don't
know anything about any of the other
variables so what happens if we set
these to be true in the model and then
just ask what's the probability of all
these other things we don't know so
here's how those positive leads update
you can see that the probability for low
energy bloating vomiting is 1 obviously
because we define that and then you can
see some interesting things like the
probability of ovarian cancer was really
low before it goes up to 90% so maybe
that's maybe can diagnose someone with
ovarian cancer using this model and then
some other interesting things like you
don't know if the person has lost
appetite but just because it looks like
they probably have ovarian cancer and if
you have ovarian cancer you usually have
loss of appetite I the model already
knows that that person probably doesn't
have an appetite so this is of course a
very toy example but models like this
are used in practice very successfully
and I there are some cases where on
diagnosis is actually this type of
basing network is actually a key part of
diagnosis
any questions about Bayes net inference
and again just to point out this is very
easy to form these things in pomegranate
all we had to do is we define the whole
model the whole structure and then we
just did predict the probability of any
given state yes
[Music]
the question is can the software handle
it there are loops in the Beijing
network so by definition something isn't
a Bayesian network if it has loops in it
a loop and if you think about from a
like a sort of causal standpoint there
can never be a causal loop right you can
ever have one thing causes something
else which actually caused it in the
first place you could have a loop in
time meaning something at time at the
first time step caused it later in time
and then the other thing caused it
backwards you know again in time and
other you know get later in time but but
never at the same time step so how those
causal loops are handled you in practice
usually is defining variables for each
time step and then and then you get rid
of the causal loops there is a another
case another aspect to this which you
might be asking about which is that not
directed loops in this graph but if you
have cases where there there's a lot of
entanglement between all your different
variables and there's a particular
definition called a tree with what you
couldn't define exactly how entangled
they are but if the graph is very
entangled then you can't exploit that
independence and get fast inference
there are a couple of different
solutions for that one is called is an
approximation method called loopy belief
propagation so pomegranate input
implements belief propagation which is
the exact method it also implements
loopy belief propagation up which does
much faster in that specific case where
there's a lot of entanglement there are
other excusing there are other
approximation methods that also can
handle that power grant implements just
loopy belief propagation does that
answer your question okay
any more questions oh it's the second
question in Bayesian networks is trying
to learn the structure of a given Bayes
net so we just have a bunch of variables
again this could be
things related to diagnosis for example
you know different medical conditions
different genetic conditions genetic
mutations out there are different
symptoms and you just want to know what
causes what this is a much harder
problem than just performing inference
there are three general ways to do this
one is called search and score others I
should say there are three categories of
methods certain score is an exact
strategy constraint learning I'm not
going to go into detail but it's
something you can google if you're
interested and then just heuristics on
that aren't exact and don't have any
guarantees but tend to perform well in
practice
so pomegranate supports methods in these
two categories so I'm going to talk
about those so I suppose you're going to
try to do exact structure inference
here's how the running time grows so in
this case we just created some toy data
and asked pomegranate to find the causal
structure exactly using the naive search
and score method so here's how the
running time grows you can see it grows
pretty fast and actually this is a log
scale plot so this is growing so a
straight line in this plot mean
exponential increase in running time
this grows faster than linear so it's
actually super exponential so that's
pretty bad now turns out you can get a
little bit better this green line is a
strategy that it's a little bit better
than this naive method but pretty
recently a dynamic programming method
was developed that does a little better
and this dynamic programming method
performs in exponential running time so
this is the first time I've ever seen
someone advertise their method as
exponential running time it was a good
thing but here you go that is a super
exponential in this case super is bad
okay but I we can we can do a little
better or we can do faster worse
performance for faster running time
using some approximations the first time
I tell you about is called the Chow u
algorithm and the tree
with the same name so what a child you
tree I'm not going to try to pronounce
this name I does is it assumes that each
variable it just has one parent so
that's a pretty strong assumption
because in most cases of real data you
don't imagine that everything is just
dependent on one of the thing there's
that assumes there's no interaction
between any of your your different
examples but you can do it and it's fast
so that's good so you can see here's how
the running time grows as you add a
number more variables and in this case
the running hat as much we're reasonable
and it's aligned would be exponential
and this is underlined so that's less
blent exponential turns out it's a
quadratic algorithm grows according to
the number of variables squared now
there a couple other of these heuristics
and pomegranate supports four of them so
I'm showing you is two plots on the left
is the running time and higher so higher
is worse in this plot and on the right
I'm showing you the ultimate probability
of the data given the model so higher is
better on this pot so you can see a
couple of different methods there's two
exact methods this teal exact method and
the purple exact method this purple one
is based on an algorithm called a star a
star is a graph search eristic you can
see the running time of these two is
pretty high but the performance is
pretty high too the two lines are above
each other the purple line in the two
line because they're both exact methods
and they're both the best performing
that Chow Lu algorithm I showed you very
fast you can see it's right down here on
the bottom of all the methods but it's
also on the bottom in terms of
performance there's another method that
tell you about in a second this based on
a greedy method this meant this was
developed in part by Jacob is sort of in
the middle it looks like the running
time not too bad and some performance is
just a little bit worse than exact so
what's that greedy algorithm
that that looks like it's doing pretty
well so this greedy algorithm is based
on this idea of a constraint graph so in
this algorithm doesn't apply if you have
no information at all about your
variables but it works in the case where
you have some prior knowledge where you
know that some set of your variables
might have influence on some other set
so let's go back to that example of
diagnosis we know that symptoms are
based on conditions meaning diseases or
whatever and that conditions are based
on genetic mutations so genetic
mutations certainly can't depend on
conditions in most cases right because
you have your genetics is what you've
had from birth so that doesn't depend on
anything and then symptoms are defined
just on the genetic conditions you have
our sorry the the medical conditions you
have not on not directly on your
genetics so we can use this structure to
constrain our are what causal structure
that we can have in our model and we can
actually perform this we can find the
structure of our model a lot faster
using these constraints now you can say
now by the way this is this is purely a
generalization of the general problem
the general problem is you just take all
of your variables and you put them in
one of these groups of variables and you
put a self-loop so that's saying that
any variable can influence any other
variable but of course you do that it's
not any faster so here's how we do
comparing the exact running time to that
constrained running time and you can see
the constraint is much faster and that's
just because instead of having to search
over all of the possible configurations
it has to search over just
configurations that follow the structure
and that eliminates a lot of
configurations
another nice thing about this is that
this lends itself well to
parallelization because if we can it
turns out that we can do some of the
computation in this leg of the model and
in this leg of the model without having
without those parts having to talk to
each other at all so we can do this part
in one core this partner other core and
have a running time okay so let's let's
do a slightly more complicated example
um so Jacob you know did this work and
decided the next thing to do is try to
make money on the stock market so so
here's what we tried to do we tried to
take on all of the top 20 stocks in the
in some stock exchange this is you don't
don't try this you're not gonna make
money off of it and Jacob didn't try
either so so don't worry and and
binarize them as either being a higher
than it's last opening or lower and so
and you can see how we have that idea of
a time scale where for a particular
stock it can it can influence on itself
in the future or other stocks in the
future but it can't influence you know
can't there's no influence that goes
backwards in time so that's how you deal
with that idea of there being no causal
loops so we tried doing the structure
inference on on this and you know made
the results who knows if it's good so
let's see we see look over here ve D
that turns out to me a mining company VZ
is Verizon so first thing the mining
company doesn't depend on anything
whether or not goes up or down maybe
that's because it just depends on you
know mineral prices or whatever so that
doesn't kind of hang Bryce and depends
on the mining company okay I don't know
if I buy that but anyway you can you can
look at this and try to make you try to
decide if it makes sense to you
presumably if you did this a little bit
better you might be able to get some
real results but neither of us are
finance people so we don't know ok this
paper by the way on this method is
coming out it's coming out in a journal
called pure J so I believe it should be
coming online today actually so Google
if you're interested any questions about
Bayes nets question yeah ok so the next
topic is going to be Bayes classifiers
so this is using these probabilistic
methods for supervised learning so
supervised learning is the case where
you're trying to again distinguish
multiple classes of things for example
spam from non-spam so what a Bayes
classifier does is it imagines that you
have different models that your data
could come from and you're trying to
predict which model it came from so in
this case you have one probability
distribution over emails that spammers
could send another probability
distribution over emails that normal
people send and then you look at a given
email and try to guess which is more
likely that it came from so in this case
we have probability of the model that
the data is drive from given the data
and we can compute this using Bayes rule
by asking to what the public of a given
model we can ask what's the probability
of the data given that model times the
probability of the data or type
probability of the model the prior
distribution
divided by a normalization constant so
it looks like this the likelihood times
the prior divided by normalization so
normalization is just there so that your
posterior distribution adds up to one so
the important part is defining a
likelihood distribution and a prior
distribution for your data in your model
respectively so let's look at an example
here's some data and it's in this case
it's classified
so the purple examples came from one
class the teal example came from the
other class and it looks like you should
be able to distinguish between these two
pretty well because looks like
everything above here so would probably
teal and below is probably purple that's
pretty good classifier so here's how
what we get if we just try to fit two
distributions on these two sets in this
case we're going to fit Gaussian
distributions so this looks pretty good
you know the tailed reduce on the right
the purple is on the left but the
problem is but this if you if you add up
these two distributions they don't look
the same so why is that well it's
because we forgot to include a prior
distribution because it looks like in
our original data that less examples are
coming from purple then are coming from
teal so what we want to do is we want to
learn a prior probability of I guess
magenta and cyan the prior probability
of magenta is less than the prior
probability of cyan so in order to use
our classifier we need to incorporate
both now here's what happens if we scale
those two distributions according to
their prior probability and this looks
much better this looks like it matched
the data that we saw before and if you
use the Bayes classifier the Bayes
classifier will give you a very high
probability if you see value here it
will give you a very high probability of
teal because it adds up the teal and the
the magenta and divides by the total so
it's much more teals and there is purple
here magenta starting over here it's
going to give you a high probability of
magenta because it's mostly magenta here
it's going to be about 50/50 because
it's hard to tell which distribution it
came from there's another variant of a
Bayes classifier called naive Bayes so
the naive Bayes is pretty similar except
that instead of having a probability
distribution over all the data together
it assumes that each each variable any
our data so if you have if it's a
multivariate distribution for example if
you have multiple pieces of information
about each example in the case of spam
you might have multiple different words
you're measuring you probably have
multiple different words you're
measuring
so what naive Bayes does is it says that
each of those things is independent so
we can just multiply them together this
notation means you take all for all the
different values of I you take you put
an I here and then you multiply them all
together this guy times this guy's have
this guy and then again same
normalization at the bottom so here's an
example when you run naive Bayes on just
two dimensions so what I'm showing you
here is each dot is a data example it's
colored by its class again either
magenta or cyan and the two pieces of
information you have about the data is
the vertical and horizontal axis
horizontal and vertical and then what
the what pomegranate did is it fit to
input one Gaussian distribution for cyan
that's like kind of centered here and
one for magenta it's centered here looks
like when jente is more clustered so it
has a smaller variance and then here
this black line is the decision boundary
so that's everything inside the black
circle will get classified as magenta
from the final classifier and everything
outside is cyan and you can kind of see
what it is cyan have a higher variance
so you can if you imagine that a point
just way off in the weeds it's more
likely that the higher variance
distribution produced that so like even
here like maybe it's more likely cyan
you can decide whether that's a good
classifier or not and change your
distribution but this is what you get
and it's a circle because of naive Bayes
because it's a I couldn't it would in
general be an ellipse but because it's
90 days it's always a circle you know
equal proportions of each side you can
do this again for things like a hidden
Markov model here's where we defined on
a a is over
sequence and you can see you if you run
my pomegranate using hidden Markov model
with cyan and magenta classes here's
what pomegranate predicts different
classes to be and you can also extract
after you run pomegranate to see what
the distribution that pomegranate thinks
are each class has so you can see it
looks like magenta has in general higher
mean and cyan a lower mean I thought
sure what's going on over here
you're
the question is the hidden Markov model
is generating this data so I believe
what Jakob did is he used a hidden
Markov model to generate the data and
then forgot about the original data and
then tried to figure out what the hidden
Markov model would be just from the data
so in in real case you would not have
you would just have the data and a
couple of labels examples more questions
okay so just another example is that is
you can apply lots of different that you
can use whatever distribution you like
to put it into a Bayes classifier could
be a normal distribution like we've seen
it could be an exponential distribution
or it could be one of these weird
distributions that we're talking about a
mixture model a hidden Markov model
Bayes net anything like that you can
define a Bayes classifier over any of
those examples now just to show you how
using a good distribution can help you
do a good job so in this case we have
some data I'm not showing what it is but
it's there's some training data and some
training labels and then some test data
and some test labels and what we're
looking at is we're comparing naive
Bayes run by a pomegranate naive Bayes
from scikit-learn which I think for
these in the very simple Gaussian case
there is scikit-learn does implement
naive Bayes and then pomegranate where
we use some more exotic distribution I
think it's a mixture of these three
distributions that were defining naive
Bayes on and then what you can see is
that pomegranate and scikit-learn do
exactly the same that makes sense
because they're implementing the exact
same algorithm and then this
heterogeneous naive Bayes strategy that
that lets you know that has much more
flexible modeling does better so this is
showing you how
having that power and that flexibility
can invert in many cases give you better
performance the question is is
overfitting what we're doing this on a
test set so we're not strictly oh we're
on training on the test data you can
imagine that maybe Jacob like look
through a whole bunch of different
distributions of kept testing on a test
data so you would want to have separate
validations that this just toy examples
so I think I don't know how was but it's
but in but in general it turns out on
real data having the flexibility does
and is often found to help so you might
worried that having a lot of flexibility
her to interpret running time turns out
a doesn't here is where scikit-learn
does implement this naive Bayes
algorithm so again this is just in the
gaussian case because we scikit-learn
doesn't implement any other cases so we
can't compare against it but for that
case scikit-learn and pomegranate have
the same running time so you're not
losing even in running time by doing
pomegranate now just reminder before we
get too far down the naive Bayes route
is that we don't need to have
independence meaning we don't have to
use too naive Bayes we can still use a
normal base classifier without that
native assumption it's a little bit
slower but it still works so in this
case um there's two two possibilities on
the left is either than ieave base it's
a two Gaussian distributions and a non
naive normal Bayes classifier on the
right now you can see the decision
boundary here that's that black line is
kind of weird like you it looks like the
teal data is sort of crossing the
students boundary you should be able to
get these guys it looks like you want a
different decision boundary and with the
normal Bayes classifier not naive it
doesn't have to assume independence
between these two axes and so it can get
a much better boundary
see it gets a lot more points correct
than this one it kind of misses up now
again just to show you the value of this
flexibility here's what happens if we
define a Bayes classifier using a
Gaussian mixture model so here's some
data it looks like you might see this
and looks like it comes from each class
comes from mixtures in odd if you try to
model do a base classifier with just one
Gaussian for each you get kind of weird
decision boundaries as you respect on
the right is what we get if we do a
Bayes classifier using two Gaussian
components and you can see is a much
better model of the data and you get a
much more complex decision boundary so
this is good and this is show this shows
how valuable it is to be able to again
have all that flexibility for defining
your the models being able to put one
model into another and just to show you
how easy this is here's all the code to
do the plot on the last page you just
define one general mixture model for one
dataset another general mixture water
from the other data set and define your
based classifier based on the two that's
it then
just I'm not going to show you data for
this but here's what how you create
Bayes classifiers for a bunch of
different categories of model you can
create Bayes classifiers over hidden
Markov models meaning you have a
sequence and you're trying to determine
which hidden Markov model that sequence
is generated from just three lines of
pomegranate you're more to define a
hidden Markov model but once you have
the hidden Markov model it's just three
lines to define the Bayes classifier
same thing for Bayes Nets okay in the
last few minutes I want to just show you
kind of a finale where we take through
all the features and a pomegranate and
put them together so we're going to
train a mixture model over hidden Markov
models in parallel
so again creating a mixture model of
hidden Markov models is really simple so
what is the mixture model hidden Markov
models you could imagine there's some
process that your output is a sequence
and what the process does at first it
flips the coin to the side which hidden
Markov model is going to use and then
depending on which hidden Markov model
it uses it runs a hidden Markov model
and generates your data so now you've
just seen the data and you're trying to
- you know define a model that captures
that mixture of hidden Markov model data
and you can use in pomegranate it's
really easy to do this you just create
your hidden Markov models and then your
mixture model mixture model can just
take in Markov models as input so here's
your model you just put three hmm as
argument now to show you that this is
paralyzed Abell so a mixture model in
general is pretty easily easy to
paralyze because you can do your
inference on each each mixture component
separately so this is what I'm showing
you what happens when you add more
threads and you have cores to support
these threads of course in order to
train this mixture of three hidden
Markov models so you can see that you
get a lot of speed up for the first once
you get three cores once you get more
than three-quarters you don't get much
speed up but that parallelization is
doing you a great job you're getting
down almost a factor of three this point
from the running time on just one core
so I'm not sure exactly when you'd want
to do a mixture of hidden Markov models
but this is just showing you how
flexible this idea of model stacking and
how a pomegranate can figure out how to
paralyze even this weird wonky mixture
of hidden Markov models method
so that concludes the tutorial on
pomegranate documentation on pomegranate
is available on read the docs so just
google pomegranate read the docs and
you'll find the documentation tutorials
ipython notebook one of these this one
here is the one I linked you to but
there's a bunch more Python notebook
tutorials I just want to put up some
acknowledgments oops
it's the some acknowledgments these are
the organizations that supported Jacob
in producing pomegranate I'm happy to
take any questions thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
question the production quality yes so
the question is how robust is a package
how well how widely adopted is it how
many people are using right now you
should ask Jacob for more specifics I
would characterize it my best guess is
sort of mid stage of adoption it's well
past sort of the initial you know just
getting off the ground stage it's not
quite this stage where like millions of
people are using it I mean this is
programs maybe thousand people using it
I believe it's on the order of maybe
hundreds of people using a couple of big
companies I believe are using it so it's
pretty pretty well adopted question what
in the heterogeneous base classifier
what were those defines I don't know the
answer I actually I noticed that this
afternoon I emailed Jacob and I didn't
hear for him so email Jacob to get the
answer to that question over here hey I
was just wondering is this package still
under active development are they
looking for more contributors to the
package are they looking for more
contributors I believe the answer is yes
message Jacob if you're interesting
contribute I think that would be super
helpful question
question is what verses are available it
sounds like two seven three five and
three six are all available question any
big projects are using it like some
source projects that are using open so
if I change other open source projects
using pomegranate I don't know the
answer that question our conditional
random random field supported there is a
package for Markov chains which may or
may not be random field I am Not sure
you should ask Jacob it's a pretty
simple addition / - go from Bayes Nets
to Markov random fields so I would
imagine it probably has but I don't know
the answer
all right several questions thanks
everyone for your attention all right
thanks again max is great cost
[Applause]